forty-eight seconds of logos primary
villain enjoys t being evil and watching
all this from a window above cliche
[Music]
thieving child mystique picks the one
mansion in the world where another
mutant lives in fact you never have to
steal again because my asshole parents
are really cool about like that
germy Revenge of the Sith so he
impressed the doctor with his abilities
and then what he just escaped after that
or the war ended and separated them it
seems like someone such as Sebastian
Shaw would have been resourceful enough
to keep the metal controlling bully in
his grasp while he escaped Germany in
case you confused it with Oxford
University Switzerland Nolan Xavier has
hot transforming mystique in his grasp
and hits on any other woman I know it's
Conan's unit and you awfully concerned
with your look
Charles has no idea how girls work in
case you confused it with Las Vegas
Michigan oh my god this is the worst
secret room activation button hiding
place ever I bet half a dozen strippers
reveal the secret room each night just
on accident
secret bad guy meeting room conveniently
has an office with no one in it so that
the CIA chick doesn't get caught
immediately in a secret office that
takes the precaution of also having a
secret bookcase that leads to another
room important files are just left out
on the desk for any asshole to find
tornado pushes him directly into the
secret bookcase door and slightly opens
it so that Maura can see everything also
every bit of action Moyer needs to see
now occurs inside of this small opening
impossible to find guy lets his picture
get taken and put on a bar wall in
Argentina this guy kills one of the men
in the photo with Schmidt that's just
stupid
at least ask him what he knows first
damn Jennifer Lawrence isn't my
girlfriend in the scene Rose Byrne isn't
my girlfriend in the scene and January
Jones isn't my girlfriend in this scene
in case you confuse it with Miami
Oklahoma then alignment edit Lindsey
come on his power is energy absorption
not recognizing grown men after having
only seen them as little kids he didn't
ask so I didn't tell don't ask don't
tell reference cliche this televised
newscast in the 60s is being transmitted
to Shaw's submarine in pristine
practically HD quality man even in the
1980s you couldn't get reception like
this even if you live right next to the
broadcast tower and where is this
submarine right now oh it's just here I
mean Russians make me this I decided to
keep this helmet down in my escape
submarine that I didn't know I was gonna
need until
Nido wreck the yah I know Magneto's
helmet is iconic but this movie is
saying telepaths can only enter the
brain via part of the head that has hair
on it and that this needs ice that's me
some Shahs a dick to the chick he's
digging whoa you are not gonna take our
blood directly over a plate of delicious
Twinkies are you
that's just reckless also someone took
one bite out of a Twinkie and put it
back with the unsullied Twinkies that's
a party found kinky Magneto's other
mutant power is cock-blocking sure we
can shave your head
contest my hair ha ha future bald
reference well the strip club scene is
gonna have a lap dance for sure how
would you like a job but you get to keep
the clothes own damn it this chick
reveals our meeting wings in front of
plate-glass windows how would you like a
job but you get to keep the clothes on
you mean like this one
this guy is addicted emos excuse me I'm
Erik Lehnsherr Xavier go piss off okay
I'm gonna have to take us in off of that
right there that's awesome all secret
rooms in this movie have buttons that
are obvious it's hella path I shouldn't
be able to feel him at this distance and
because you can shouldn't Charles be
able to see what's going on in the
submarine you've got four mutants on
this thing you should be Professor X and
you should be magneto iconic characters
apparently get their iconic names from a
partying teenager I really like this
actor and I don't mind seeing him in a
lot of movies but does it say something
that I knew the Russian general was
gonna be played by this guy before I
even saw him up close don't worry you
don't have to say a word WMDs Eric left
way earlier and was on a mission of
vengeance but politely waited for
Charles to catch up before bursting into
the room I know her diamond form is
screwed now but isn't she still a
powerful telepath she has no mental
defenses now somehow this plan is
ridiculous with a telepath and a guy who
can transport anywhere he wants couldn't
you just control the right mind and fire
nuclear weapons from either country and
start this nuclear war that you want
Cheryl is a nicer Shana commissioned
this neat little animation of his
nuclear war plan so that Charles could
get the details and it's a sync manner
hey come on honey give us a little
that's racist
Oliver splat when you can do this and
this
and this and this and this why do you
even need the USA and the USSR to bomb
each other but you can do all of this on
your own in half the time at least I can
take this silly thing off yeah but why
would you want to risk that you don't
know the abilities of these mutants
you've seen to telepaths in this movie
and maybe Charles is running around the
corner geez what a dumbass
also are we bothering with fries after
all the dead people you see out here you
had the advantage and you blew it so the
whole reason for this attack on the CIA
was to take the mutants they had inside
but they take one the one who can fly
and shoot fireballs what be fit and then
they call this a job well done and
they're ready to leave you could kidnap
all these kids and if any of them resist
or try anything you could just kill him
so tell me about your mutation Shaw
waste time asking Darwin what his
mutation is instead of getting the hell
out of there adapt to this is there any
reason why he couldn't that wasn't clear
enough that's why I've decided to speak
English to the Russian man right now we
can avenge him let's have this private
conversation five feet from everyone
walking is hard
this bolt scene is only here because
January Jones is a big enough star now
to get X amount of lines and X amount of
screen time but it has zero to do with a
story or my interest dispatch the
seventh wait wait these assholes all
trained up in the time it took the
Russian ship to reach Cuba that's like a
week or two at best right rapid
superhero maturation is rapid in case
you confused it with Moscow off
screeching practice can Banshee repair
his own bones in addition to the
screeching the scene kind of contains a
lap dance it's not a complete one but
it's more than most movies do mannequin
fondling and try not to hit me I've
complete and utter faith in you but
seems like this is unnecessary and even
if he hits it it's a small sample size
anyway the world is primed for war and
there's no one to stop me except for all
those good mutants I left alive back at
the CIA place and Charles and Eric but
aside from them no one scientist running
out of time and/or funding test its
theories on himself cliche also the
movie recycles the Cure the mutants of
their mutation serum plot device from
x-men The Last Stand at L ready I want
to go to bed man
no one wants mystique do they ha ha
Rebecca romaine is married to Jerry
O'Connell now I said the real Raven
movie reinforces the stereotype that
some women will sleep with the first guy
that thinks they look pretty without
their makeup off military air base
during the Cuba
missile crisis somehow not off-limits to
little-known mutant CIA Division members
where's Hank
I'm here I needed to make this dramatic
entrance in case someone asks that
question it didn't attack the south and
enhance them wow that makes you like the
opposite of a good scientist then right
how do we end up with this formation of
ships when the US was trying to block
the speaker and these Russian ships were
actually chasing it god help them if
they cross it god help us all god help
us all cliche geez he's an expert pilot
and plane designer to his accurate
mutant serum development the only thing
this guy isn't amazing at all the
important characters survived the
combination submarines stealth fighter
crash wouldn't have expired cause just a
little bit more than a heart thrust into
the submarine shouldn't Riptide be on
fire right now
Azazel decides to fall 50 feet before
dropping beast and havoc allowing them a
chance to escape when earlier he was
raining CIA men from the skies like he
was in a weather girl song we go you go
just because you change locations does
not mean you change momentum you are all
dead right now
both Banshee angel fight scene keeps
getting in the way at the cooler far
more interesting Eric versus Shawn fight
Kent Charles just make Shawn duck the
coin I'm sorry I Magneto you don't have
any more missiles to control anymore at
least you shouldn't and that's the story
of how Charles got in a wheelchair
amazing that with all these mutants and
special abilities not one of them has
healing powers jeez how long does it
take for missiles to fall down I think
I'll be going bold haha future ball joke
again gentlemen this is why the CIA is
no place for a woman
that's racist
[Music]
go ahead take the blood the power of the
Sun in the palm of my hand do you want
to be responsible for the extinction of
the human race can you handle that
Adrian I'm so long
[Music]
sir your mutation is what you're super
smart I'll say I don't care garage ready
to have it at the age of 15 I wish
that's all it was you're among friends
now you can show Geils
[Music]
you can stay fight for the people who
hate and fear you or you can join me and
live like kings
[Music]
just let me get to my house okay we're
gonna do that sweaty I'll give you my
whole body okay we're gonna do that just
throw the gun out the window okay we're
not gonna bother we're gonna let you go
up there just throw it out the window
what are we calling a hundred and forty
third Bob we are quickly being reduced
to a very low order to less than 15
minutes from now the rustlers will be
making radar contact with the plains
Judy I'm doing it in my office
wherever the engineer about the
possibility of going to 105 percent of
the reactor engineer reports 105 percent
on the reactor possible but not
recommended
they're heavily John